they own the microphone that's that's
what
the crazy part is and it's like all of a
sudden you you don't talk their talk and
walk their walk
then they just shut the microphone off
or take it away from you hey everyone
welcome back to led live
what happened to hip hop find out on
this episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness well we want to
thank you guys for
joining us for another episode of led
live today we have a guest on our show
his name is akande
davis and akande is going to talk to us
today
about hip hop so akande welcome to the
show
we're glad that you could join us today
and uh
we're very interested to see what you
have to say
about this subject i'm curious
are you uh are you someone who used to
listen to hip-hop
yeah i used to and i still do um not the
same anymore not the same kind of
hip-hop but
yeah absolutely um hip-hop was a way of
life when i was a kid
you know and growing into it as with a
lot of things in life
music is one of those things that's
super impactful and super influential
for
any youth kind of growing up right if
you ever want to know what a kid's being
influenced by why they dress the way
they do
listen to the things they do watch the
movies they do you can usually
pinpoint a lot of that into music um so
when i was like 10
10 or 11 i first uncovered this awesome
thing which
maybe some of you guys know it was kazaa
or limewire
yeah it was like the the napster 2.0 so
i kind of started bootlegging a lot of
music and
you know really snow holds bar which is
kind of a crazy thing to think about but
you can download anything so
i would downloading a lot of m m 50 cent
um pretty much anything that came out i
was hooked
and i would listen to as much rap as i
possibly could um
so fast forward about 10 or 15 years i
went i just had a choice choose where i
wanted to go to school
and there was a university in florida
called um but my heart and my mind was
set on i want to make it in the music
industry
and this is the quickest way that i
could do that i'm going to become a
recording engineer
to get my foot in the door so yeah fast
forward i went down full sail and that's
really when
all the layers started peeling off and
the things that i
treasured so much and i thought were so
awesome got a lot
darker and uh the the real meaning and
message that was embedded in the music
was
blatantly revealed to me you know i used
to listen to a lot of hip-hop growing up
as well
and i know i know i don't look like
but no seriously like i i think hip-hop
was probably my
favorite genre of music you're laughing
you know like come on man
no but i i i used to listen to a lot of
it and it does seem like it is getting
increasingly dark i don't know i mean i
i haven't listened to it in years
and the little amount that i haven't
been exposed to it um
it's like whoa man this just seems like
a lot more darker than what i remember
it to be
this weird hip-hop it has like this
style that just kind of crosses all
boundaries because
now you hear it in country music and
stuff you got this like
yeah country rap crap i guess is what
you call it
[Music]
and they've got a way and like yeah so
it's like in pop
you just hear the rap influence the
hip-hop influence in
all genres anymore i think that's
interesting
well and what was what was kind of i
guess revealed to me
in the most profound way was not even so
much
the content so like i would listen to a
ton of really misogynistic songs
you know songs about dealing drugs you
know you're gonna shoot this guy or get
this guy before he gets you
and none of that really bothered me but
as i started kind of uncovering
some of the other elements of it um
that's when it really kind of took me
back and
i don't know maybe it's because i don't
know why this is the case but usually
when
um something is kind of covered up or
the devil tries to cover something up
with something attractive and once you
take off that attractive layer and you
kind of see it for what it is it becomes
really unappealing right so
when i started looking into hip hop a
little bit more and learning about
kind of what i'm going to cover here
this secret society
kind of connection and the hidden agenda
behind it i was like whoa this stuff is
a lot more
evil and has a lot more hidden within it
than i originally thought
and i think that's kind of what hit me
so it wasn't even like i was listening
to this
song about hey i'm gonna go shoot this
guy and sleep with your girlfriend
and i was like oh i hate that stuff it
was more like whoa
this guy's connected to this and this
why this symbolism is in it and
you kind of start digging a little bit
deeper and you're like wait hold on
dmx is talking about his deal with the
devil and all this kind of stuff and i
was like whoa
this is not what i signed up for more or
less and um
yeah that's when it really hit home for
me at least so in particular in
in kind of this led live what i wanted
to cover was hip-hop
secret societies and a hidden agenda and
really how hip-hop has kind of turned
into this thing where
there's there was kind of a shift in
where the content might have been
negative
and now the content has a complete
hidden agenda that's being more and more
blatantly shown in the videos
in the song lyrics and pretty much
everything associated with hip hop
um so when you think about secret
societies i mean for you guys
you know i know you cover a lot of this
but what comes to mind for you and
obviously i put some
some very popular symbols up on the
screen but what comes to mind when you
think secret societies
i think dollar bill freemason illuminati
george bush dark in the shadows 9 11.
i think it's really the people that are
like running the world behind the scene
and it's like nobody really knows the
full truth about it
it seems like there's been a lot of
speculation so far
that people discredit it because they're
like well nobody can prove it but i i
think it's totally real there's there's
there's secret families and things that
are that are behind the scenes that
are actually running the world yeah
actually and you guys hit on a lot of
the things i'm gonna cover so you know
first off yeah like
when somebody thinks secret societies
usually they think conspiracy theory
which
you know makes sense and i'm not
necessarily saying that every secret
society
conspiracy theory is true and i don't
even want to dive too deep into that
but when you think of freemasons or
skull and crossbones or the bavarian
illuminati
started by adam weishap a lot of those
elements are carried into hip-hop
and we see it very early on in the art
form so hip-hop came in around like
mid 80s mid-1980s late you know
late 1980s early 1990s but around 1995
was when you started seeing the first
kind of peaks of illuminati and
freemasonry and new world order being
mentioned in rap
so as we kind of go into you know a
little bit about this i wanted to give
it some context
the first time that i was able to really
find when this kind of came up is from
an
artist by the name of prodigy prodigy is
an artist that was part of this group
called mob deep
and one of the lyrics that he had in the
song he was featured on with ello cool j
was illuminati wants my mind soul in my
body secret society trying to keep their
eye on me
now this was pretty unstandard for
hip-hop
and as soon as you know someone like
prodigy who was at the top of his game
he was 18 19 at the time
says illuminati wants my mind soul in my
body you know that just kind of opened
the floodgates for people to try
secret societies illuminati for a
culture that had never really been
exposed to it
so this was kind of a big stepping stone
in hip-hop to start a
lay the foundation of hey what is this
and
is it in the art form and to kind of
piggyback on what
what scotty said these secret societies
are kind of associated with running the
world
and there's no reason that music or
media or hip-hop
even is kind of going to be left alone
you know it's going to be out of that
equation
so it was interesting seeing prodigy
talk about this in this song
yeah he he's really deep into uh stupid
societies i know he has an album called
the hegelian dialectic
if that's correct and um yeah it's
pretty much just the philosophy used
within secret society that whole concept
of
creating the desired effect out of chaos
create peace out of korea
so the same person who creates the peace
is the same one who created the chaos
so i mean this is just it's a rabbit
hole you can spend days
years of your life trying to just wrap
your head around what's out there
what i think is so interesting is how
they are so out in the open
like they'll talk about it in in in
terms of like this is what we're doing
and you know this is where it's going
and
but it sounds so ridiculous so it's like
hiding in plain sight sort of
yeah yeah when you hear your lyrics
they're constantly saying
i sold my soul to the devil and people
like then man you're crazy they didn't
sell their soul the devil well listen to
this lyric this lyric this lyric oh it's
a metaphor
it's just something to you know sounds
cool
yeah i think the oldest thing i've ever
heard about the illuminati i don't know
if you're going to touch on it and i
didn't know about it
until later because you hear these
things as a as a child i mean i was
in elementary school here in tupac
[Music]
and there was a record after he died
that came out and showed him on a cross
and it had a little warning under there
so this is not a mockery of jesus christ
or something
but it was called machiavelli and that
was his new name
and which was a person who faked his
death or something
and i think the album title was called
killuminati
and i had no idea what that was back
then but i started watching
interviews with tupac and he said yeah
when i was in prison i started hearing
people talk about the illuminati and
stuff and
and uh he started digging into it i saw
i saw interviews with tupac where he was
actually
coming out saying i'm sick and tired of
them trying to run me and
control me and tell me what to do that
might have been dmx
tupac was too much yeah i've seen some
interviews with tupac saying the same
thing too
do you think so it could be sort of
compared to a concept so anyone with
those type of tendencies or
seeking that kind of control they can be
labeled the illuminati
that's why you keep hearing it pop up
yeah it's kind of an interesting thought
that you know
like tupac for example he he pulls
a lot from historical figures so
obviously there was a historical figure
machiavelli and yeah he calls himself
machiavelli
and then that idea of kill illuminati he
literally talks about you know taking
down the illuminati more or less
um but there's kind of a a separation or
distinction i've i've really noticed
where
the illuminati is closely tied at least
in hip-hop culture
with like world takeover right and
freemasons are kind of like in the u.s
and they're not as powerful as the
illuminati but the upper echelon
of freemasonry is is in with the
illuminati but
the idea of illuminati could really be
from a hip-hop cultural standpoint
anyone
who's in power who's in a lead and who
has control of this
this whole culture right this whole
hip-hop culture what what's popular
what's not popular
what gets traction what doesn't get
traction um
so i don't think yeah hip-hop doesn't
really define there's this one
group of people you know and sometimes
you'll hear like bilderberg group
mention that kind of thing
or bill gates is you know kind of the uh
in the crosshairs quite a bit but yeah
it's never
really nailed down it's just kind of
like this thing you know
it's kind of like control or something
like that so to give some more context
around it i also wanted to bring up
goody mob and then another group called
poor righteous teachers who both came
out in 1995.
so this is kind of you know coming off
the piggyback of prodigy talking about
this
where they talk about you know tagging
your skin
new world order cell therapy
manipulating dna
if you advance just one more slide for
poor righteous teachers
they have a whole album called new world
order where they take a clip of george
bush senior talking
and they literally you know point to the
fact that george bush is saying
what's at stake is more than one small
country it's a big idea a new world
order
so in 1995 is really when this idea
started bubbling up
the reason i kind of give this context
to lay this groundwork is because i
think
the idea of secret societies in hip-hop
and systems of control
can really be drawn to one artist in
particular who really went
all the way to so to speak and that
artist you guys have covered before
but that's jay-z
so let's talk about h to the izzo v
to the is a mr j
yeah so jay-z obviously one of the
biggest artists of our time
when you think about a rapper when you
think about worldwide acclaim jay-z is
up there
probably one of the most celebrated rap
artists of all time so he came out in
1996 with his album the blueprint
and the album itself is riddled with
a lot of um a lot of different kind of
what i would say a cult symbolism
but what's in in particular is he has a
song
on uh his album uh reasonable doubt
where he says i never prayed to god i
prayed to gotti
that's the um that's right it's wicked
the life i live it ain't asking for
forgiveness from my sins and ends
and then he goes and he says um stop
screaming you know the knee the demon
said it's best to die and even if
jehovah witnessed
but he'll never testify so he's really
kind of taking it to that next level and
on this song
on the chorus he samples prodigy saying
illuminati wants my mind soul in my body
and he even samples another artist
saying the new world order's coming to
take over
so he kind of i don't know what this
song in my opinion puts a stamp on where
he kind of stands
and the whole song is pretty dark pretty
evil
but this is the first peak that jay-z
kind of has as he's getting his foot wet
into this kind of secret society occult
symbolism
right we can't pick and choose with this
if music is an expression
of the artist and you hold it to a
standard just because they
they release something that you don't
agree with or you think
they're making fun of you can't detach
that from the person you can't like pick
and choose
which song right yeah i'll buy the album
but i only listen to these certain
tracks or something
i have heard people say that you know i
just skip over this one song but yeah i
mean clearly he's
into this you know and
my philosophy too when approaching it is
you know if an artist has one song and
they talk about something
maybe they're not sold out to that one
thing right but you kind of
expect to see a pattern if they're
really into this thing or if they're
into
whatever they're talking about for any
artist for any person for anything
there should be a pattern that exists so
another
kind of indicator of this pattern that
exists is that same time
he started his own record label and his
record label was actually called
rockefeller records
now you could do a little bit of digging
it's not hidden it's not veiled
but this was actually based on jd
rockefeller and the rockefeller family
so the rockefeller family you guys will
probably be able to speak to this as
well but
one of the richest families in history
of the united states
very powerful very influential and very
synonymous with freemasonry and secret
societies because of
the statute that they have when you
think of rockefeller plaza with the bull
out in front and
just really the name itself and the
weight that it holds i think is very
telling
of why he made the decisions that he
made everything is done with intention
right so
in any kind of art when you make a
decision it's very intentional why you
made that decision
yeah i think we kind of as try to
establish this with our
analyzation of movies it's like if you
if you have one particular director that
makes
a certain type of movie you can make an
assumption about that director but until
you see
other projects that that person has
worked on and they're all similar in
that vein then you can pretty much back
up and say well they're either into this
or they're
totally tied to this theology or
whatever and i think the same thing
exists here if if jay-z's coming out
with one album he's got all these things
and then he's
naming things and putting the symbols on
his on his artwork and
you know you can pretty much be like
he's pretty tied into this
yeah it takes an incredible amount of
work and they're investing into this so
the fact that
they're not in line with it is that
would be a surprise to me
now and kind of like religion like you
know you sit down you talk to a
christian enough times you're going to
hear the buzz words you're going to hear
the things that are
connected to their life because that's
what you're into and it's like this is
what he's into
and so you're going to see this
dovetailed through all of his art
through all of his lyrics and
you know like uh lecrae said a i'm not a
christian rapper i'm just a rapper who's
a christian
and it comes out in my lyrics or
whatever right i've never seen this
logo i thought rockefeller records had
like a
a face of a kid or something but it
looks like a
hypnotic bottle of potion or something
i just think that's interesting it kind
of reminds me of uh 36 mafia their their
record label was hypnotized minds they
had a grim reaper with a
pendulum clock and it's like they're
telling you right now we're
hypnotizing you hypnotized minds
yeah i mean the name three six mafia
even
like i don't know people just kind of
move on by that because they like the
songs but
you know you know spiritually spiritual
things are spiritually discerned so
um and again this is kind of a trend and
a pattern so
as we go on to look at his sophomore
release and i'm sorry earlier i said
that was blueprint his debut
reasonable doubt was his debut blueprint
was a sophomore but this is when he came
out with a song called izzo which is one
of his most popular songs
and when he kind of again really starts
saying a lot of things that define his
character and define his artistry so
this is where he introduces that
pretty infamous line h to the izzo v to
the is a
and he spells out hovo and if you know
anything about hip hop
everybody calls jay-z hova jehovah
obviously you know we can make that
connection pretty clearly because we're
christians but
jehovah's the name of god in the bible
right or at least one of the
interpretations of the name
of the tetra gramaton so the fact that
he's calling himself hova that he's
calling himself god
really should make people step back and
as we'll look into some of these other
you know pictures and whatnot he's very
closely tied with the five percent
nation
who believe that they are gods and
themselves
or even with freemasonry that you ascend
to a spiritual a higher spiritual plane
a higher spiritual understanding
so again i i was kind of blind to this
for a long time this was one of the
first things that kind of
someone pointed out to me and hit home
like wait why why
am i calling him jova like what does
that even mean and then
you start comparing that with scripture
and you even just see the name right
there it's like
jehovah like whoa this guy is calling
himself god
that's right it's those questions asking
yourself those questions really bring
things to light
are you going to get into kanye's kind
of connection to him at all right they
were used to
oh yeah absolutely okay yeah what's
interesting is
jay-z and again i think he's the pioneer
of this in a lot of ways but
all of the major major artists came
through a couple of people
one was cash money records who was
literally birthed some of the biggest
artists in the world drake nicki minaj
little wayne
but jay-z as well so every artist that's
been closely tied to jay-z has
blown up from kanye west to rihanna
beyonce in particular as well
um j cole you know not saying that every
single one of these people has
direct ties with secret societies or
whatever but he's kind of like the
flagship person that's taking these
artists
and blowing them up and then we see that
same pattern and imagery throughout
their music as well
question can you detach secret society
from just
skill so can it be said that hey give
jay-z his props maybe he's just really
good at what he does he's
really good in the industry and he can
take a talent and blow them up it has
nothing to do with spiritualism
spiritualism or secret societies
yeah i mean i i would probably say
all things considered you can blow up an
artist
without all of the secret society stuff
for the most part right and what i kind
of mean by that
is obviously these people have to be
somewhat talented
obviously rihanna can sing obviously
beyonce can sing kanye west is a great
artist
like these people that are tied to him
they have talent but
when you think about kind of the system
and the music industry itself
it's a system of control and there is an
agenda that needs to be pushed
so if you go along with the agenda or
you're allowed
you allow yourself to be coerced into
pushing the agenda you're going to be
fine
and you might even advance further
depending on how far you want to take
that agenda
but when somebody comes up to you and
says hey this is how we're going to
shoot your music video and you push back
and say
i don't want my music video to include
that or hey i want you to say these
things
these lyrics from this song i don't want
to say that in this song
then you're going to kind of be fighting
that system and
i mean you know i don't want to jump too
far ahead but
like with kanye west for example he was
nothing he was nowhere but on an uphill
trajectory for a long long time right
and you'll see that his career and what
he did and what he said
aligned perfectly with the agenda that
was being pushed but on his most recent
projects he's kind of deterred from that
agenda quite a bit
and you see the machine kind of turn on
him you know i personally think his last
album jesus is king is one of his better
projects but really bad critical acclaim
low for sale first week sales numbers
botched rollout
it just kind of seems like as soon as
you start going against the machine
they're going to kind of pull away their
support from you so that's that would
kind of be my answer is the talent does
have to be there and people can get
successful from just their talent and
their hard work but there is a ceiling
to it unless you want to go with the
what the machine says they own the
microphone that's that's what
the crazy part is and it's like all of a
sudden you you don't talk their talk and
walk their walk
then they just shut the microphone off
or take it away from you and then what
are you going to do go stand on the
street corner and talk to
a hundred people so it's like they've
got this
machine that is that is very difficult
to
operate outside of that machine and it's
real easy for them to cut you off
if you don't play along with what
they're doing yeah it's like us
trying to get our content out there
without youtube we're not going to use
youtube anymore well good luck having a
channel
yeah i mean if we had to literally boil
it down to dvds and panhandle them out
the back of our cars i mean
we'd reach a few people but not like we
would
just because we're using their system
yeah i've noticed
what you're saying um lately it seems
like the talent isn't even there anymore
though
you got the mumble wrappers and
everything so you see the the person on
the bridge
playing and they're just like man they
sound amazing they got a great voice
they
playing the guitar and you're like why
aren't you signed
well because there's something that
you're signing to
when you when you sign a record deal so
i think um
like you're saying you know if you if
you don't have the right
agenda you don't have the right look the
right words the right music video or
whatever
then you're never going to get anywhere
and i know with michael jackson
he started speaking out at concerts he
was telling the crowd about
you know that um the owner of sony is
the devil and this and that and
everybody's all
cheering yeah yeah and he's like don't
let this go in one ear and out the other
and it did you know they were just
cheering because michael jackson's
talking to you
but they're they weren't getting the
message what he was saying and
and what i've seen in his life was that
he did have talent he he had the singing
the dance and all that and he really
didn't need the label he could have
started his own label same with prince
but both of those people had their image
attacked
big time and with prince he wrote the
word slave on his face
and he had his own record label and i
don't know if michael jackson ever had
his own record label but i know that
um he was speaking out against the label
and
yeah you see where they're both dead now
i mean if that means anything
yeah yeah i mean in a in a recent
interview kanye west with joe rogan was
saying he's been speaking out against
record labels as well if you guys have
followed that at all and he's been
saying like
um you know we're slaves essentially we
should own our masters this is the new
me too movement people are getting taken
advantage of
and with joe rogan he was talking about
you know i see what happened to michael
jackson
i see what happened to prince and it
makes me think
and the insinuation was that he's going
against the labels and he's going
against the powers that be
could something happen to him and i'm
not saying that you know i don't want to
dive down that trail
necessarily but it's just kind of
interesting to think that
the most prominent artist probably one
of the most prominent artists in the
world
is saying that in response to his
rebellion if you would against the label
it's fascinating because you just see
how no matter what system it is
or or you know what world it is
the devil always has the same tactic and
it's
either you either do it my way or i'm
going to shut you down right
yeah and so when when christianity
spring up in the first century it was
like oh no no no i'm gonna shut that
down
right god has never never
been like that god is like you know what
i'm
so confident that my way is going to
work you can say whatever you want
and in the end you know i'll let you
play it out so you can try to prove your
point
and you're going to prove that it's not
going to work and in the end yes
you're going to be destroyed because i'm
going to let you take that full course
of freedom
to show that what you're doing doesn't
work the devil doesn't let you get that
far he's like no no no it's going to be
my way or you're going to get shut down
yeah but isn't that isn't interesting i
mean
jumping off of that thought i mean
that's why god said i'm going to lay you
before kings they're going to see what
you're all about i'm going to pull the
wool off their eyes
and you're going to see how the end
conclusion of this happens but it's like
this
this this way that the devil operates
you do it or i'm going to kill you or
take you out or whatever
and then that's his accusation against
god like oh you just want to force
people and you're going to do it and
it's like he's throwing that at god's
face but that's really how he operates
yeah wow it's so true and it's
incredible
to to hear that i mean
when we get into this and you kind of
see how far these artists are willing to
take it
it makes you think like is there no
limit you know and
is that fear looking in the back of
their mind that they could just have
their career ended their livelihood
taken away
if they do anything but follow kind of
the trend
um so this next slide again just kind of
continue to build off of this
this habit in this context i'd like to
give the context because i think it's
important for people to understand where
i'm coming from
i really don't like to have someone be
like oh this person
said one thing in this one song or he
wore this shirt one time and that's
their entire identity
um but we can see up here in this uh on
this slide upper left-hand corner
jay-z wearing the five percent nation
chain which he's worn quite a bit
if you guys are unfamiliar i would check
that out anyone watching the five
percent nation
is um a group of uh religious believers
i believe islam and origin
who believe that five percent of people
are aware and woke to the idea that they
themselves
are gods and like literal gods capital g
um his shirt do without wilt this is
coined from a lester crowley who was you
know called the most wicked man in
america
the fact that he's rocking that
merchandise and has other merchandise
with
similar imagery similar um you know
all-seeing eye that kind of thing
one of his most famous signs is actually
a mudra so
the diamond the the rock that he calls
it that he throws up
um is actually a um
maybe you have to speak to us a little
bit better like i don't know how to
describe a mudra but essentially it's a
gesture
that invokes a spirit is essentially
what it is from what i understand
and he's always putting his eye through
it for that all-seeing eye so again this
pattern of behavior and lyrics and
the lyric that i have up here is from
one of his more popular songs called
empire state which features alicia keys
and he says hail mary to the city you're
a virgin and jesus can't save you
life starts when the church ends so
again these
consistent lyrics consistent themes
consistent topics
really to me paint a picture of what he
is trying to push and and where kind of
his his allegiance lies when it comes to
secret societies or anything like that
and it's so crazy because that song is
iconic
i mean that goes on and new york city
goes crazy but then there's that one
line in the song and it's hard it's hard
to throw out a whole song because of
that one line
especially because of the energy that
that comes from it so
yeah who is the gentleman in the top
middle there
that's the founder of the five percent
nation i forget his name i think it's
muhammad
farah something like that but he is the
founder of the 5
nation you know throwing a mudra over a
audience
um i remember seeing a documentary about
led zeppelin one time
and um jimmy page when whenever he would
play
um the guitar he was real big into
witchcraft fact he bought aleister
crowley's house
did all this like witchcraft stuff and
and when he would play his guitar he'd
play it with a bowstring like you would
a violin
and he would do this east-west thing
like this over the whole audience and he
was like literally
casting a spell as they're sitting there
listening to him so
you know that scares me when when when
jay-z's walking into an audience and
he's holding up stuff that's invoking
spirits
you know he's pulling him into that room
it's a giant worship service you know
and then h to the izzo comes on
yeah and you know we're saying
hands up in the air you know i mean it's
just like abs
absolutely and um to speak to candy's
point too
you know that idea people are so
attached to songs
and so attached to like the way it makes
them feel
for me it was like that for a long time
but what i kind of found too is that
once i started
understanding these truths and things
were being revealed to me
and even even empire state is on an
album called the blueprint three which
has a ton
a ton of symbolism you know more than
i'm going to get into right now
but i just realized like if i allow this
in my life still
the way that it makes me feel is not
going to be worth the consequence
of the strongholds that i'm giving to
the devil or to
um like demons that might want to attack
me because i'm putting this in my life
and i'm putting this in my mind
and even when you don't verbalize a
lyric
i know for you guys i know for myself i
don't know about you guys but when i
commit a song to memory
i can literally do the whole song from
memory you know
even if i don't say it i still think it
you know so even if that song wants to
play and i'm like i'm not going to say
that lyric i'm still thinking and i'm
still hearing it
and i'm still participating so you know
i would encourage anyone if you have a
hard time letting go of some of that
music just
think about the spiritual implications
and you know where you want to be in
your walk
as a christian or even someone just
trying to um you know clean up
clean up the type of content they listen
to absolutely and i wanted to add to my
point that
it it speaks to the devil's tactic that
yes it's going to make you feel good
it's going to probably seem right just
like that little drop of poison in the
in the juice
so having that line is actually enough
to toss the whole song
absolutely i just wanted to bring out
something that jesus said because
art is an expression
right it's an expression of what is in
the heart and mind
that's that's why you do it whether it
be poetry
or music or painting or what have you
it's an expression of what
what's inside of you and jesus said in
luke
6 45 a good man out of the good treasure
of his heart brings forth good
and an evil man out of the evil
treasures heart brings forth evil
for out of the abundance of the heart
his mouth speaks
[Music]
art is essentially a way of speaking
right it may not always be with words
but it's speaking
and that's what is inside of you it's
what's in your heart that's being
projected forward so
you know if it's not good one has to
question
you know like what's in the heart and
mind if the expression is
not lining up with things that are
biblical yeah keith but i don't i don't
listen
to the words i'm here for the beat what
do you have to say to that
well you watched a couple weeks ago we
had a show on music and we talked about
the beat and everything too
that's right well what's interesting too
is someone else might even say
like oh well jay-z didn't write that
song or rihanna didn't write that song
someone else wrote that song for her
she's just performing i can assure you
that whoever's writing it that same
scripture is true out of the abundance
of the heart the mouth speaks so
anyone writing it anyone producing it
you know even with the beat too like
i don't really have a huge issue with
like hip-hop beats you know like
there's a certain line i'll kind of draw
but
there are i've been in studio sessions
with with producers
way back when there's a lot of drug use
there's a lot of like
colors there's candles lit i don't want
to say it's like a seance necessarily
but something is happening
right something is happening during that
creation process and whatever is present
in that room is going into that music so
you might listen only to the
instrumentals but i promise you
something is happening there as well so
good thing to keep that on music is a
spiritual experience i mean
i remember watching an interview with
kanye west
in fact candy showed me this interview
and it was
amazing how he started talking about
when he started making christian
um you know his sunday service and he
started making music that was that was
leaning for the sunday service
he was like i'm not going to play the
this particular drums
here i'm not going to play this
particular things here and he said it's
not appropriate in this setting and to
me i was like whoa
like there's an appropriate time and
place for all these different things
and and i think there's some things that
are not appropriate in that
setting for sure yeah and the bible
takes us seriously whether it's
our words or not you know where it says
guard the avenues of your soul and speak
only that which is pure
life and death is in the power of the
tongue it doesn't matter if it's your
words or not if you're
constantly saying it it's impacting not
just you but those around you
if you're reiterating it yeah you know
whether you're the listener who's
who's listening to the song that the
artist is producing or whether it's the
artist
that's you know delivering it from
somebody else who wrote it
you you only s you're only going to be
speaking things that you believe
yeah right that's that's just the way it
is i'm not going to go around
quoting john dunn from 17th century
if i didn't think that what he had to
say was
worth repeating yeah so
yeah i mean whether they wrote it or not
the fact that they
agreed to sing it on a record shows a
lot about their character you know
and that's that's part of that coercion
process right so
the devil always wants you to submit in
in just a little bit
you know give in a little bit a little
bit more a little bit more and before
you know it
you're the frog in the pot of boiling
water so
to kind of piggyback or to segue into
this jay-z i think is the pioneer for a
lot of this stuff and he's not the only
person pushing this agenda
obviously but he's one of the leading
people and everyone that's tied to him
are some of the biggest names in music
so the the first person which is going
to surprise a lot of people that
really kind of bought into this and
became a part of this
i don't know what you want to call it
right like the secret society or this
this formula for being successful that
involves occult symbolism
and taking part in this is actually um
beyonce
so if you guys are familiar with pop
culture at all um beyonce went so far as
to
uh come out in 2003 and she she and
jay-z were starting to date right
and this music video comes out called
crazy for a song called crazy love
and that was the birth as we'll see a
little bit later where she becomes
sasha fierce and she actually comes out
with this album
called um i am interesting use of
i am dot dot sasha fears um it features
songs called halo if i were a boy and i
mean
you could see in some of the the lyrics
here
um and some of the imagery you know
making horns on herself
because she's saucer fierce she has
paint on she's wearing a baphomet head
on her shirt
um the rolling stones do the cover story
and it's you know says a woman possessed
um and there's a video actually that's
going to come up um after this as well
where
she's with oprah and she talks about how
sasha fierce possesses her and
as she goes on stage she becomes this
new person right um
it's also interesting that halo the
leading single on this album
um had a couple of lyrics in here that i
want to point out so
um remember the walls that i built
they're tumbling down they didn't put up
a fight they didn't make a sound i found
a way to let you
in but i never really had a doubt
standing in the light of your halo i got
my angel now
and in in the in the pre-chorus she even
goes to say
it's like i've been awakened every rule
i had you break in the risk that i'm
taking
i'm never gonna shut you out this is a
really powerful
you know like these lyrics mean
something and
the way that she's saying it if you
watch the music video even she's
sleeping
and she lifts off the bed like if you've
ever seen those witchcraft movies where
they're bent over backwards
they look like they're being possessed
same thing in this music video for halo
so there's no doubt in my mind that it's
some sort of form of demon possession
that she's pushing
and this sasha fierce character like she
says is literally taking control of her
yeah i don't i don't know of anything in
the bible that talks about
a good angel that you can find a way to
let them in
i know about legion and that's not a
good angel but
when it says i found a way to let you in
that sounds very demonic possession and
i don't think it can be
i don't think that can be flipped
there's no place in the bible that
actually
tells it's okay for an angel to be
inside of you
we know that that can happen through
demonic possession we know those
are fallen angels that can do that but
there's nowhere that says a good
angel would ever enter into you for any
reason
that's not his place that's god's place
and you know like god
god's he's supposed to be the one that
dwells inside of us and we pray that god
will dwell inside of our hearts
but the devil has usurped that and and
come in and taken control
wow and yeah if you want to um
these are words coming out of her mouth
so anyone saying that sasha fierce is
xyz
just listen to exactly what beyonce is
saying so
like when you're getting ready to go on
stage and performs is sasha fierce when
does she
show up usually when i hear the crowd
when i put on my stilettos
um when like the the moment right before
when you're nervous and
and that other thing kind of takes over
for you uh-huh then sasha fierce appears
and my posture and
and the way i speak and everything is
different but no is it like
a process that happens too like you were
talking about the high heels like
once the lashes go on and make up and
all that stuff it's kind of like when i
do a movie becoming the character once
you put on the wig and once you put on
the clothes you walk
different yeah it's kind of this
character that i've i've created over
the years
uh-huh and how is sasha fierce different
than i am
well i know you know definitely wearing
that bodysuit i could never walk out
here and do this
does sasha first ever go home like um
sometimes but
[Laughter]
shows up sometimes in the house
yeah but definitely when i'm nervous or
or um whenever i have to perform
whenever i have to
do choreography or something that's
difficult and i
it's no different from anyone else i
feel like we all kind of have that
that thing that takes over when it's
interesting she related what she's doing
to acting yeah just leave that there
yeah no
i mean that's something that we've
discussed yeah that we discussed on this
i mean
i took acting classes and that was one
of the methods that they really taught
you to do is to empty yourself of
yourself
and to like let this other character
inhabit you so that your
thoughts and your actions and everything
were actually you know what that
character would experience and and
often some of the activities that we
would do in the acting classes
was take a shower so what we would
pretend to do is like you know scrub
ourselves and do all these stuff and
then if your character would do that in
a certain way
fast slow whatever you're thinking those
thoughts and it's really training
yourself to open yourself up to this
other
character that's not you so
what what i think is also interesting is
how she's literally
like this is a this is a christian woman
that has come from i mean wasn't there a
band originally called destiny's child
right and and like didn't they have like
a lot of christianity type
almost imagery even in the very
beginning they started in the church
yeah she started singing in church right
right and so this is not somebody who is
completely
unaware of the the world around them
that there could be a spiritual
influence around them and yet she's just
totally openly okay with saying that
that that that is the case yeah i wonder
where that started to
become a slippery slope like when what
happened
yeah what happened to the other two
chicks and destiny's child they're
probably still christian hopefully but
she's the one that rose to fame right
right until there's a reunion and the
paycheck's good you know
we could we could wait a little bit you
know i'm just kidding but yeah it's
it's very interesting how that i don't
know how that kind of
like her expression of it is that
something is possessing her
um this is a quote from african bambada
that i think is a good
just middle point here this is a guy who
pretty much helped found hip-hop
one of the forefathers of hip-hop and
you know he
literally says i absolutely think
there's a luciferian conspiracy
to take over hip-hop and he goes on to
kind of express that these people
putting on
the music they don't really know what
hip-hop is they're just kind of
following this
agenda and really at the end of the day
you know hip-hop's been hijacked and i
thought that was just kind of an
interesting quote
um primarily because this is one of the
forefathers of hip-hop right if anybody
knows
the roots of it what it's meant to do
what it should be
it would be african bambada so him
coming out and saying that
on a public forum like the chicago sun
times really spoke a lot to me and uh i
thought it'd be valuable to put it in
here yeah that's that's pretty eye
opening i mean
what are you saying though i mean you
can literally prove it
you look at fresh prince of bel-air and
some of these old
rappers from the 80s like the humpty
humpty dance and all the stuff
like those songs were mostly about
having a party having a good time yeah
they might have been about immoral
things like girls and
and it but then it became gangster rap
which even got more immoral
but they still weren't talking about
sacrificing people or they weren't
putting
uh satanic symbols on their albums and
then look at it today i mean we can
prove
exactly what he's saying that a
luciferian conspiracy is taking over
hip-hop
over time it's it's it's interesting
because it's like
why why hip-hop you know like
you know like just hear me out because
you don't see a lot of that in country
right
yeah i mean yeah i mean there's other
genres it's just like you don't see a
lot of this so why hip-hop
over like other genres like why hijack
that
i don't know but just remembering the
episode on music we did previously i
wonder if it's like the frequency
it has anything to do with the frequency
and and what's actually happening within
the body
and how those messages can be received
better with that frequency versus
country or any any other one yeah i mean
you got to figure
you know at the end of the day a lot of
it's about money
and so the people that have money
they see there's something there that
they see some potential
right some opportunity for gain
and with you know generally with money
not in every case but generally with
money comes power and control
it could be a lot of culture yeah it's
interesting
it's just fascinating i think i think
like how akande opened up this
conversation with saying like you know
hip-hop really
touched every facet of your youth and
your childhood and
you know it was like a big influential
um part of your growing up
um you know i don't know maybe more
people appeal to
that type of like you know cool factor
um you know the style of clothing or
whatever and it's
maybe easier to emulate that that not
everybody's going to wear snake boots
and a
big old belt buckle you know yeah maybe
this is just
some genre that actually appeals to a
wide variety of
that's exactly what i was going to say
you know satan wants to get the most
people cast the biggest net so yeah back
when i was listening to
gothic metal all this stuff it was full
of occult imagery but not many people
were listening to it it didn't
wasn't even on to mtv or anything but
you can ask
almost anybody what's your favorite
style of music somebody might say
country well i hate country despise i
could never listen to it
but all those same people i bet if you
took a poll there'd be
rap would be hip rapper hip hop would be
like the biggest
out of everybody's uh should google this
yeah
i mean there's something about the beat
that makes you nod your head even when
me and my friend were making dark music
there was something about we were like
we want it we want it to be
metal but we want you to be able to bob
your head to it so we threw hip-hop
beats in there just so you could have
this
head bob factor because of how versatile
it is you could throw hip-hop in
in country here we go this is from
statista okay this says
as of may 2018. here we go
number one the p the people that they
pulled in the u.s
pop was 56 country
was 49 almost 50 rnb
in seoul was 38.9 and hip hop was 34.4
so that's not really that high yeah so
it's like you know i still go back to
like you would think
pop yeah you know well what's
interesting
is that most of the big pop songs that
come out
usually feature a rap artist on them so
i wonder how many
of people's favorite pop songs include
some sort of
rap artist as well you know can you
speak to what pop is and
it's not just popular music so that can
kind of go across the whole spectrum
once it's popular or is that incorrect
yeah i mean you could definitely yeah i
mean pop music is definitely popular
music but there's a sound to it it's
usually
a singer you know you usually don't have
like pop rappers maybe sometimes someone
like flow rider
but if you think of like pop like justin
bieber i mean
the pioneers of pop madonna michael
jackson
it's really gonna be singing primarily
and
um yeah it's usually gonna maybe more
recently incorporate rap but
rap and hip-hop is kind of like a
specific style of music like
fast cadences um maybe some singing
elements of auto-tune 808 pop music
doesn't usually have super heavy 808s
for example so maybe but the satanic
stuff's infiltrating that too look at
kesha and lady gaga these are
pop stars with occult imagery everywhere
yeah if you go back to the beginning
of hip-hop though it was a genre that
was designed to
like have a cultural voice i mean it was
like people were frustrated with the
things that were going on around them
and it was kind of like uh you know the
rhymes and the things were to deal with
the world that was around them and then
now it's just it literally has been
hijacked into this luciferian
you know agenda it's crazy here's crazy
though just as we're talking about this
i was kind of you know looking further
down the line hypebeast is reporting
that nielsen
music um says that hip hop was the most
popular genre of 2020
of 2012 okay so over the years it's
become more popular i guess i mean
look at the number one on charts for a
while was
cardi b whap i mean that's just
mind-blowing in itself
yeah i was going to cover that their
video and all the cult
symbolism there were just too much there
is there's no good way to bring that
song
i i try to keep it concise as possible
but literally nowadays
every single major artist and every
single major video
has occult symbolism in it there is not
one that doesn't
well i take that back maybe someone
like j cole i don't know even then
it's a little bit more veiled but it's
always very blatant
every single time without failure you
can you know you can find it just like
with most movies today you know
you know what you're gonna get right
from the trailer and it's the same thing
i almost feel like you know even they
know we're at the end of time even the
devil knows we're at the end of the time
and he's just like okay time to ramp it
up no more i can't hide this in like
every 10th video it's got to be in like
every video yeah
speaking of that exactly have you seen
busta rhymes latest stuff
oh don't don't spoil it i'm gonna talk
about that i'm gonna talk about that
no uh but no yeah i mean it's it's
everywhere um
the the next artist i wanted to cover we
know we kind of looked at beyonce and
you know we we don't have enough time to
cover lemonade and
um her most recently released disney
plus film africa is king
lots of stuff in there but the next
artist i wanted to talk about was kanye
west
now kanye west has recently come out and
repented for a lot of his stuff and i
think
you know for lack of an entire context
of you into his life i think he is a
genuine
repentant believer in christ and i i
really do believe that
if he sticks to it and he just can keeps
you know committing himself to christ
i think he can have an incredible
christian walk and we can all witness it
it's not to discount him being eclectic
or anything like that
so as i'm diving into this i want to
talk from that context of i do think
he's repented for this
but for the longest time kanye west was
one of the premier guys pushing
this occult symbolism most specifically
i think it really ramped up to 11
because it existed before but it ramped
up to 11
on his album my beautiful dark twisted
fantasy so the first single on this
album was called power
and power is this single shot video
really iconic the way that it was shot
but you see a ton of symbolism just in
this three minute video
with this single shot that's just
panning out the first thing that you see
right away
is kanye was standing in between these
two pillars which is
very clearly masonic imagery um whenever
there was initiation
or the ladder of ascension is always
between these two roman style pyramids
the giant horus necklace that he was
wearing for the entire promo of this
album as well
you know the all-seeing eye is commonly
attributed to being the eye of horus
so another very blatant occult symbolism
the two angels those two demons i would
call them standing on the left and right
of him as he kind of pans out at the
very beginning
um you know can be drawn back to a lot
of things aside from just the demon
imagery but
in egyptian times um there was often sun
discs with
ox horns and they would place that on
the head of kind of the guardians
of whoever it wasn't and then of course
at the very end of the video there's
this
very veiled but clear to see when you
watch the video
a freemason compass that kind of pops
out at the very end
to kind of form it um if you can advance
to the next slide as well these kind of
go hand in hand but
my beautiful dark twisted fantasy also
had aside from the song content because
there's a lot of it there's a song
called devil in a new dress where he
literally chants the name satan so
pretty crazy there but
there's a short film in which a angel
falls from heaven while he's driving
hits his car he gets out to look at the
angel and the angel comes with him
he goes to make music he starts
producing the angel starts dancing this
woman
he goes out to dinner with her
introduces him to all his friends and
then at the very end of the video he
tries to reject the angel and the angel
ascends
into heaven and essentially turns into
like a fiery
ball or a star and blasts into heaven
this is a short film
accompanying the actual album and in the
right-hand corner you guys can see
the original cover art for the album was
actually kanye west
fornicating with an angel right so
this kind of imagery to me what's a
fallen angel
who's the only fallen angel that we see
really attributed in the bible
who dances to the music is making kanye
west almost produce better music
and this idea that they're sleeping
together or some sort of
relationship is happening it's really
blatant
and when i first saw this you know this
this was after my time at full sail
after i'd kind of come full circle
but just seeing this play out in real
time knowing that
it existed i was just blown away on how
blatant it was and
i mean i don't know if you guys have
ever seen this but what are your what's
your reaction when you see something
like that is it
oh this is creative or is there a deeper
meaning that's veiled there
we're not talking about spaceships and
and alien
technology here you know what i mean
like there's so many things to talk
about
it's like why does it always gravitate
to this literal
like war between god and satan or this
angelic
christian ideology that's placed in
these things it's like to me
when you have a pattern like that a
pattern denotes intelligence
that intelligence to me tells me there's
purpose behind it and if there's purpose
behind it what are they trying to say
that seems like a lot of dark imagery
it's not teaching you how to be
a more righteous or better person what's
amazing to me that when we talk about
these things
more than one occasion people have been
like
not everything's about religion why are
you trying to make everything about
religion well because the anime calls
them mr satan and there's a car that
says 666 like
we're not making it about religion they
are and why are they making about
religion
those people creating it are yeah right
which makes you question
is this real i think that's the thing
about looking into this
is it's like hopefully the audience that
that is watching this and maybe be on
the fence or whatever it just
would have that question mark in their
head and say you know what
there is something to that i mean if
there's so much of this imagery in there
then maybe i should look into it yeah
and this all kind of ties
into really what that question is why
right and i think the why when we look
at hip-hop secret societies and that
final point hidden agendas
the why is i think to make people more
and more numb to this
so that younger and younger audiences
can commit these songs to memory
can attend these concerts and really
have their lives
saturated so heavily with the presence
of the devil
and demons right like i just to be very
cut and dry
when uh when an album like this comes
out or an artist becomes
you know comes out and blows up i think
every single song i think every album i
think every music video
has a very deep meaning and a very
profound effect on the people listening
or watching
so when i see an artist you know not to
drift too far from the point here but
when i see an artist like the weeknd
who's been consistently putting this
kind of symbolism who's been
consistently putting this kind of
message who has very explicit lyrics and
very explicit
imagery and all of the stuff that he
does when he's gonna perform at the
super bowl this year
and 40 million people are going to have
their eyes on him or when beyonce
performs at the super bowl and 40
million people are gonna have their eyes
on him
what i see is just a mass worship
service for the devil
and i think that when we partake in it
we are definitely
doing something more than just putting a
song in the background we're definitely
taking a step and allowing something
into our lives and i think that's the
real reason
it's so that the devil can get as much
worship as he possibly can
and he can tap the minds of the younger
audience because you know
the way that you raise a child they'll
stay with it until they're an adult
scripture says that i think the same is
true across the board i think it's a
universal truth whether they're going to
be raised up with christian values and a
love for christ
or they're going to be raised with other
values and a love you know
of of the world you know you brought up
something that was kind of interesting
to me
when when we were watching that clip
with beyonce how she said
um sasha fierce always shows up when i'm
about ready to perform
and you know that's kind of an
interesting thought because it's like if
those
demonic entities are literally the ones
that are
up front getting all that worship i mean
that's the end goal right they want that
worship i mean that's that's exactly why
lucifer
did what he did he wants that worship
and so maybe this is a way for them to
vicariously
live through those eyes and then receive
that worship and then as soon as that
that concert's over they're like
forget this body gone yeah they get to
stand on stage and look at a sea of
people raising their hands and saying ah
beyonce or whatever yeah and
yeah it's a big it's a big old worship
service and
the audience for these musicians is
trending younger and younger
so when we look at now 2020 2018 2019
there's artists that are like so blatant
that i can literally walk up to one of
these kids
that is a fan of these artists let's
look at this right and they'll be like i
don't care
this guy in particular his name is
little uzivert
lil uzivert that's lil lucifer right
you guys don't pick up on the on the
phonetic you know how that's being
pronounced
um he has a song on his album xotor life
that's called 444 plus two two two
i mean he talks about how all of his
friends are dead
how he wants to commit suicide um in his
music videos
he you know there's like i can't even
show some of this stuff is so graphic
like people are dead
like people are dead they're dead
walking all this kind of stuff it's just
crazy
his lyrics are written in aramaic but
they're written backwards which is
really which which a lot of witches and
witchcraft use to cast spells is
backwards aramaic
and read scripture back on a video he
literally says he sold his soul to the
devil
uh i mean it goes on and on and on and
even the fact that
he wears upside down crosses and that
kind of thing as well but
this guy is in your face blatant about
it and is one of the most popular
artists in hip-hop right now and has
been for like the last two or three
years so
if if that doesn't kind of you know
spark someone's
awareness i don't know i don't know what
else could his name is little uzi vert
i'm like come on people but
the the themes and the symbolism has
been so blatant that i think people are
dealt to it as a result
yeah i think when it's constantly in the
background like this as well
i i think you just kind of get numb to
it like you said and you get sleepy to
it
you know what i mean you're not awake to
it and these other artists as well you
know
these are young kids like i mean he
might be 24
there's other artists as well three of
them have died in the last three years
these all have been very popular artists
with the same kind of things talking
about the same kind of things
and i think there's something sinister
about music from a artist that's passed
away being released even more
and the images that they use in their
music videos so
um there's a guy x extension who came
out he
did an ig live right before he died and
he said if i have to be a sacrifice
i don't care yada yada yada there was a
twit a tweet
a tweet that went out on twitter saying
that he's gonna die today
um he had like a music video where he
was hanging a small kid
like the the symbolism is rampant and he
was killed he was murdered
another guy juice world who you could
see up in the right-hand corner dance
with satan one of his songs
um overdosed on a plane ride he took a
bunch of drugs on the plane and arrived
dead at the location the guy on the
lower right hand side his name is little
peep you know multiple songs talking
about he's meeting satan
satan's coming to get him another guy
who died of an overdose
so the agenda here i think is
all about what he can do to hijack the
youth
and twist them because i'm not listening
to these guys most of my peers aren't
listening to these guys but the kids
are the youngest age group and you might
be able to pull this up keith if you're
able to but
the youngest age group for hip hop is as
early as 13
to 16. so when you have these types of
images and these types of lyrics being
committed to memory by these young kids
i think the ultimate hidden agenda is
that he could steal the youth away from
us
and train them up to be soldiers for his
for his army i know that sounds really
grim and really
you know you know really scary or like
maybe i'm thinking
you know apocalyptic here but when i see
that we're in the end times and this is
what's being pushed so heavily to the
youth
that's the one thing i kind of drop is
that they're looking to numb
us so that when it's time for that
worship to happen when it's time for
those
end time events to take place they're
perfectly primed to accept whatever's
fed to them
i mean it seems like every generation
has had this sort of
you know rebellion especially in the
music industry
rebellion against the parents the system
and it's like a separation like get the
kids away from the parents
and then you know send them to the
concerts and teach them these ways
through
this you know music industry and stuff
um
i mean i remember like the 60s you know
hey teachers leave them kids alone you
know like that kind of
mentality has been sort of in all the
genres not just hip-hop
and um you definitely see it pretty
heavily in hip-hop
did you find some statistics on it yeah
i was looking and
you know you definitely see that of
course the first one i could pull up was
only
you know like from 16 to 19. and you can
definitely see there
they're they're definitely into hip-hop
and into pop music
it's weird because you you mentioned
like as young as 13 but i
i think kids grow up with music in their
life all their life i mean
even even the kids cartoons now like
there's a new one
called trolls or whatever and it's all
about music oh yeah yeah the whole thing
is about noisy
and uh one of the guy one of the
characters has auto-tuned voice and
stuff like that
but i remember being exposed to rap
music
basically all my life as long as i can
think back to
and and those were the years when i was
in elementary school
hearing snoop dogg and and tupac and all
that and
bone thugs so i mean i was really young
and music is more and more accessible
than ever before it's ubiquitous so
if you have a phone you can get spotify
pandora
youtube if you have you know um
three or lte like sell your data you can
listen to it whenever you want
most of the time for free with ads so
it's not even like
oh you have to save up your 20 bucks and
go to the store and buy a cd or even you
have to have a computer with
internet that you can bootleg one song
that takes a day to download you can get
it on demand
instantly or whenever you want yeah or
have batteries for a big boom box or
whatever you know it's just in your
pocket
i mean i remember those days i was
talking about was snoop dogg
like it was an audio cassette tape and
you're not going to listen to that
unless you're in a house most likely or
in a car but
yeah like you're saying you can be
anywhere and listen to your phone but
you know to conclude this i know this
has kind of like been doom and gloom and
i definitely don't mean it to be but i
think it's important to kind of
look at these things and understand them
and hopefully this can help people
inform themselves better
on tick tock i've been making a lot of
these short clips and kind of sharing
with people
and the response has been overwhelmingly
this makes so much sense
i used to chant this song you know and
being able to reveal that i think is
important because people might have good
intentions they're just not aware
um but looking at scripture uh psalm 101
i think is really important and
something that i kind of turn to
and meditate on and recite when i think
about things that i watch or listen to
and psalm 101 3 i will set no wicked
things before my eyes
i hate the work of them that fall away
it shall not cling to me a perverse
heart shall depart from me i will no not
wickedness
when you're committing these song lyrics
to memory you're listening to it all the
time you're allowing it to inhabit you
affect your mood i think that's exactly
what david is warning against here in
this psalm
also first corinthians 2 14 but the
natural man has not received the things
of the spirit of god for their
foolishness to him
nor can he discern them because they're
spiritually discerned i think a lot of
this too just flies over people's heads
because spiritual things require
spiritual discernment
and if you're not aware or spiritually
considering what you're watching or
consuming
i think it can just zoom past you so we
really have to pray on these things
obviously and
allow the holy spirit to lead us and the
last verse that i wanted to mention here
was primarily um revelation 12 9
and the great dragon was cast out that
old serpent called the devil in satan
which deceiveth the whole world so the
whole world is being deceived so
the idea that we can know better and
that we can
say you know we're not being affected i
think is kind of silly i think we have
to
call upon the holy spirit it might have
been the music one that you guys did
with candy's mom when she was talking
about like the survey that was done and
everybody thought that the music or
whatever they did affected them the
least
and in reality everyone else was
affected but they could control it i
think we have to be careful because
if we're not we can be deceived and if
we're not using that discernment of
christ we could definitely um
we could definitely fall um into
temptation
i just want to um kind of circle back to
what you were saying
the the first scripture you quoted was
from from which book again
uh psalms from the psalm 113 and
what are most of the psalms
yeah right absolutely and
you know if you think about that god
knew
and you know he he's the one that made
us he he created us he knows how we work
and he knows that we have a better
memory
when things are put to music you know
for
for remembering them and you think about
all these psalms that are written a lot
of them
are they're praise to god they're meant
to be uplifting yes some of them
talk about the times of despair and
things like that
but but i would say a good majority of
them are meant to
encourage you and and be uplifting in
the book of revelation
there if you read read the book and it's
it's a little hard to tell
in a king james but in a new king james
you can tell a little bit easier because
it
it denotes the poetic parts there are
multiple songs in the book of revelation
i think this information
was incredible and and good for us to
know
when you're dealing with what i should
and shouldn't listen to and maybe you
find like this really nice song
but it's a little ambiguous and you're
not really sure what they're getting at
i would say consider the source you know
go and look at the person and what they
believe their lifestyle see what they're
involved in
find those patterns and track records if
they have a career you're going to find
something and and i absolutely pray ask
the holy spirit to guide you in the
decisions that you make and the media
that you choose to consume
yeah word of caution though um it is a
rabbit hole
it is very dark and it is very deep and
i don't know if anybody's ever seen the
bottom of it
so you can actually fall off into the
rabbit hole and it gets weirder and
weirder that's what they call the
bottomless pit
right and so you know just just word of
caution
we need to not be ignorant of the
devil's devices
this is why we do this on the show is to
to allow people to say hey look
there's there's a war going on around us
right we need to be aware of what
what's being thrown at us but at the
same time
it can suck you in and blind you from
the real
um focus and that is a relationship with
jesus so you know
keep that into perspective whenever you
start looking into this kind of stuff
and um you know this is really about how
does this fit into our relationship with
christ
right good point well said man and you
know the one thing that i found
coming from full sail when i was so
wrapped up into this
and so determined to be successful and
so
you know wanting that stardom i did go
down this rabbit hole and
i fell into a pit of despair and i was
like well what's even
real you know because obviously this can
dovetail into a number of different
things with secret societies and all
this kind of stuff
and kind of what i've found to be true
and scottie we kind of said this but
the closer i got to christ the easier it
was to make decisions about
what i would listen to or what i would
watch and what i would put in
and if anything even gave me a moment's
hesitation
i would just either cut it out or just
be like
i could find something else you know and
if if that song comes on i'm not going
to be offended by it
i'm not gonna worry about it but i can
find something else
and you know in the same way that when
you guys talk about media on your show
which is
really hit home for me a lot is you know
we don't live just to watch
television you know so if something is a
offensive to god
we really shouldn't try and navigate
like oh let's watch a little bit of it
or watch some of this
or what can i watch i can't watch
anything it's none of it's edifying
hey well that's might be a good thing
right so
so yeah i think there's just that level
of being cautious about
like everything doesn't need to be
explored every conspiracy doesn't need
to be dip
you know dove into and um you draw
closer to christ and you know that
discernment will be there
thank you guys so much for having me on
honestly it's been a blessing to share
and i hope people
are really edified by this and walk away
with something
that is powerful and profound and
hopefully can make them just
turn on that little light bulb and then
change up their spotify playlist
that's right akande that was really cool
you said you had a
a channel or something that you were
putting videos out on tick tock uh
do you want to oh yeah share that with
people so they can find out more if you
if you got other things you get you want
people to look at
yeah absolutely so if you guys want to
see more content like this i dive into
specific songs
and artists and reveal this in a little
bit deeper way on my youtube channel
it's just
fl forever fl forever and on tick tock
you can follow me at floodlight forever
where i kind of do the exact same thing
i do some other creative things as well
to glorify god but
we you know we look at like one little
60 second clip that we could fit in
and try and dissect it in the best way
possible because obviously there's time
constrictions but
on youtube i'm doing the same thing and
i've done a few videos on even record
contracts and how record contracts can
exploit people for slave labor
and how that could be used in the
manipulation and coercion of people
um to push this agenda out so yeah would
love to be able to share that with you
guys
um if anyone wants to check that out and
uh yeah big fan of little light studio
has been watching for a while so
god bless you guys ministry it's been
incredible we really appreciate you guys
joining us today and we hope that you
learned something
um music is a powerful force and it
teaches us something you know those
lyrics
they they speak to us art is an
expression and we should really be
asking ourselves
what is in our heart you know and if our
heart is not
filled with the goodness of god maybe we
should be reevaluating
you know what our circumstance is so we
thank you guys for joining us we'll help
you join us again for another led live
and we will see you next time
[Music]
visit our brothers at school for profits
dot tv and watch from babylon to america
which has over 5 million views on
youtube alone
and follow it up with america 2 babylon
check the description below for links to
this and more
[Music]
you